dach zusammen herzlich willkommen zur
zdf heute live mit ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
und werde die deutsche regierung noch
zögert wie es in sachen corona pandemie
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
weitergehen sollte haben unsere nachbarn
in uk und in frankreich heute mal eben
nägel mit köpfen gemacht
die einen machen den laden auf die
briten und wollen den freedom day den
freiheitstag feiern die anderen die
franzosen sprich der französische
präsident makro wird wohl das gegenteil
beschließen in ungefähr einer halben
stunde will er vor die kameras treten
und eine rede zur lage der nation halten
wir wollen darüber reden heute mit
unseren korrespondenten in paris und in
london
diana zimmermann in paris thomas walde
umgekehrt diana in london thomas walde
in paris und mit dem professor für
klinische pharmazie thorsten leer an der
universität des saarlandes über die
frage ok welcher weg ist denn jetzt der
richtige in welcher situation lockern
oder beschränken vor allem auch da für
uns in deutschland
ihr könnt wie immer mit diskutieren eure
fragen und kommentare sind richtig
wertvoll und werden hier von mir
möglichst mit einfließen lassen
eingeflossen lassen wie sagt man hasst
ich werde sie mit aufschlägen in die
diskussion die adresse kennt ihr zdf
heute.de zdf.de oder in die dafür
vorgesehenen kommentarspalten das ganze
posten aber damit wir überhaupt wissen
worüber wir hier reden fast und thomas
konsul die ganze lage in frankreich und
in uk noch mal zusammen ein präsident
ein premier ein problem delta und zwei
unterschiedliche wege
frankreich will wohl neue massnahmen
beschliessen großbritannien die
geltenden aufheben
wir glauben jetzt ist genau der richtige
zeitpunkt für öffnungen wenn jetzt kommt
ein natürlicher schutz durch die
schulferien großbritannien lockert
obwohl die inzidenz mit 327,7 sehr hoch
ist in frankreich beträgt der wert 39,5
aber mit steigender tendenz
allerdings stehen die briten bei den
impfzahlen besser da 67,6 prozent sind
mindestens einmal geimpft gut die hälfte
vollständig freilich mit astrazeneca das
gegen delta nicht der beste schutz ist
in frankreich hat dagegen erst gut die
hälfte überhaupt die erste impfdosis
vollständig geimpft sind 36,1 prozent
die delta variante sie herrscht vor
das haben briten und franzosen gemeinsam
und doch wie gesagt sie gehen
verschiedene wege und über die möchten
wir reden wir hören dass beide
den regen die an nationalen london und
uns beide in verließen stoff für ihr
haltet durch thomas wir fangen bei dir
an präsident micron hat angekündigt er
wird eine rede zur lage der nation
halten
das klingt ein bisschen düsterer als
freedom day freiheitstag ist dann schon
durchgesickert was er da verkünden wird
also es gibt ein paar hinweise darauf
ganz offensichtlich will die regierung
hier deutlich mehr druck machen sich
doch impfen zu lassen vor allem nachdem
zahlreiche appelle das zu tun denn in
der vergangenheit nicht so gefruchtet
haben wie es vielleicht nötig wäre
darüber nachgedacht wird ganz
offensichtlich so etwas wie eine art
impfpflicht einzuführen für bestimmte
berufsgruppen im gesundheitswesen etwa
und wer am öffentlichen leben teilnehmen
möchte künftig hier in frankreich muss
nachweisen dass er getestet oder geimpft
ist wenn man so heißt es in diesen
plänen ein zug benutzen will wenn man
eines restaurant will wenn man ins kino
will
zwar hat die regierung bislang eine
allgemeine impfpflicht für die gesamte
bevölkerung abgelehnt aber das ist so
etwas wird dann wie eine impfpflicht
durch die hintertür genau was wissen wir
denn in einer knapp halben stunde
woran liegt denn das dass die franzosen
da so zögerlich sind tatsächlich sind
sie ja was die vollständig geimpften
angeht haben wir gerade gesehen im
beitrag noch hinter uns deutschen und
wir haben ja schon gesagt wir sind zu
langsam
ja es ist so langsam im vergleich zu der
virusvariante delta die sich jedoch
wieder deutlich schneller verbreitet so
viel schlechter als in deutschland muss
man sagen sind die zahlen nicht aber es
gibt ganz offensichtlich eine ganze
reihe von menschen die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen
das hat zu tun auch mit einem misstrauen
gegenüber der regierung mit einer
impfskepsis die jedoch hier insgesamt im
land sehr weit verbreitet ist und damit
dass man das bislang nicht tun musste
wenn man hier am öffentlichen leben
teilnehmen wollte die von den öffnungen
profitieren alle in restaurants können
alle gehen
theaterkarten können alle buchmann
musste das bislang nicht und da ganz
offensichtlich wie die regierung die
schraube jetzt doch deutlich an
wie lassen sich denn die franzosen davon
beeindrucken also
jetzt ihr leben einfach und halten sich
nicht an die maßnahmen und was heißt das
dann für unseren frankreich im urlaub
sollten den lieber sein lassen
also wie sich das auswirken wird
in frankreich muss man mal sehen es gibt
noch ein weiteres element das er mit
hineinspielt bislang waren tests für
alle in frankreich kostenlos unabhängig
davon ob man hier lebt man franzose ist
oder besucher da hat die regierung ganz
offensichtlich auch vor da ein bisschen
die schraube anzuziehen das auf dem
herbst solchen test nicht mehr für alle
kostenlos sind es würde auch den druck
erhöhen sich dann doch vielleicht impfen
zu lassen
das ist für besucher auch vielleicht
hilfreich zu wissen dass wenn man hier
künftig herkommt frankreich hat bislang
alles getan grenzen immer offen zu
halten hat immer auf europäische
lösungen verwiesen
das deutet darauf hin dass man weiterhin
besucher hier auf zu lassen wird aber
dann bitte schön mit einem nachweis dass
man geimpft ist oder mit einem test der
dann gelegentlich gegebenenfalls auch
kostenpflichtig sein kann
thomas walther vielen dank für diese
informationen aus paris und wir schalten
weiter in dem londoner regen so diana
zimmermann
dazu wird es mit komplett nass um sich
herum
diana präsident micro hat oder selbst
eine rede gleich halten
die anbindung von boris johnson sind
drittel chemie ist gerade nicht was hat
er denn jetzt kommt ihr angebot
[Applaus]
also er will auf jeden fall an seinem
festhalten der wusste ja schon einmal
verschoben werden aufgrund steigender
infektionszahlen aber jetzt will er auf
jeden fall des nächsten montag freedom
day ist und freedom day bedeutet dass
alle restriktionen fallen sollen das
auch massenveranstaltungen wieder
möglich sind und eigentlich sollte es
auch bedeuten dass sowohl die
abstandsregeln als auch die masken
pflicht fallen
nun hat boris johnson ist aber doch ein
wenig mit der angst zu tun bekommen
heute nämlich klang eher so als wollte
er die verantwortung einfach auf die
bürger abschieben sie sollen jetzt dafür
sorgen dass die sicher sind sie würden
es wurde nicht erwartet werden kann der
regierung dass jetzt gleich wieder
wieder arbeiten geht das könne man
selbst entscheiden und natürlich sei es
auch angeraten in vollen innenräumen
masken weiter zu tragen also die
strategie ist eine völlig andere
sie überträgt tatsächlich verantwortung
von der regierung auf den einzelnen
bürger
jetzt haben wir ja gesehen wie das im
wembley gestern abgegangen ist während
des wm-finales auch bei anderen fußball
spielen wurde dann munter miteinander
auf den rängen gekuschelt und dann auch
hinterher vor dem stadion in dem papst
lagen sich die menschen in den armen wie
schätze die briten bei 1 sind sie
tatsächlich dann auch bereit ist alles
selbst zu übernehmen die verantwortung
oder drittes kind
wir müssen wieder trainiert
[Applaus]
also hier das ist hier natürlich wie in
anderen ländern auch dass das
unterschiedliche einschätzungen sind es
gibt eine umfrage nach der die hälfte
der briten der ansicht dass es zu früh
diesen freedom day zu feiern
diese der ansicht der restriktionen
sollten lieber noch ein bisschen
aufrechterhalten bleiben andere dagegen
tun jetzt schon ohnehin was sie sowieso
getan hätten mit oder ohne restriktionen
das geht natürlich wirklich sehr weit
auseinander die lage hier ist ein
bisschen anders weil wir über die hälfte
der bevölkerung komplett geimpft haben
deswegen glaubt boris johnson auch dass
das zumutbar ist aber natürlich ist die
sorge gerade bei leuten die verletzlich
sind sehr hoch dass sie sich jetzt doch
auch noch anstecken und natürlich ist
das problem nach wie vor dass leute die
nur einfach geimpft sind sie geben auch
noch mit data anstecken kann so jetzt
habe ich gerade einen kommentar der geht
in unsere richtung können wir kurz mal
zeigen
stevie möchte wissen warum hat das zdf
nicht über die proteste gegen die korona
maßnahmen in london berichtet ob es eine
million menschen waren weiß ich nicht
vielleicht was die ananas aber es nie
eine ganz einfache schnelle die besucher
gibt sie zum beispiel diesen artikel von
sternberg auch um mobile in london da
haben wir 28 06
getestet berichtet in den kommenden
jahren aber auch noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen also es gab tatsächlich
diesen mut in der türkischen bevölkerung
neben hypo roma-politik der puppen bast
hatten die direkt oder was sie konnte
auch zu setzen naja das ist die hier der
gleiche unmut immer dass deutschland
auch kennen das ist natürlich viele
unternehmer die sich bedroht fühlen das
sind menschen die der ansicht sind
corona sei eine erfindung immer noch und
es gibt viele die eben der ansicht sind
die eigene verantwortung müsse gestärkt
werden und die regierungsmaßnahmen seien
zu rigide gewesen erreicht hier nicht
das ausmaß der proteste in deutschland
insgesamt ist auch zum beispiel die
bereitschaft sich impfen zu lassen sehr
viel höher als in deutschland
aber es gab immer wieder proteste und
wir haben tatsächlich darüber auch auf
verschiedenen plattformen berichtet also
haben wir gemacht wird unsere pflicht
nachgekommen
dann werden erstmals die neue auf die
neuinfektionen puppen diana in uk die
steigen ja die sind bei einer relativ
hohen instruments von weit über 300
haben wir gerade gesehen richtung 400
erwähnen betreffen
das war so lustig der vollkasko pudel
sagen hat so viele sind davon besonders
betroffen
[Applaus]
für die jüngeren jüngeren die noch nicht
geimpften insgesamt sind 93 prozent der
jetzt erkrankten nicht oder nur einmal
geimpft 7 prozent sind doppelt geimpft
also auch da gibt es menschen die so
wenig immunität aufbauen durch die
impfung dass sie immer noch an
weltweiten können aber in den
krankenhäusern sind jetzt insgesamt
deutlich mehr jüngere als vorher das
führt natürlich auch dazu dass es
deutlich weniger todesfälle gibt die
jüngeren eben die erkrankung besser
wegstecken als die älteren was
allerdings befürchtet wird und das ist
meiner ansicht nach wirklich eine große
sorge ist dass die zahlen hier bis auf
100.000 fälle am tag wieder steigen
könnten
und er sagt jetzt natürlich die
regierung dass es nicht so schlimm denn
es trifft ja vor allen dingen die
jüngeren die das gut wegstecken können
was sie dazu nicht sagt ist dass man
davon ausgehen kann dass bis zu zehn
prozent der menschen an longo wird
erkranken
und dazu gibt's hier zum beispiel gerade
eine neue studie aus bayern die sagte
dass patienten von longo wird rote
blutkörperchen aufweisen die weniger
elastisch sind und weniger flexibel sind
deswegen die muskeln nicht richtig mit
sauerstoff versorgen können und daher
würde so könnte man diese
ermüdungserscheinungen zum beispiel
erklären die bei longo wird auftauchen
sehr unschöne erkrankungen die das sind
die unter umständen sehr lange anhalten
und dafür hat natürlich auch der
gesundheitsdienst hier große sorge denn
es gibt seit dem letzten jahr einen
gigantischen rückstau an behandlungen
die aufgeschoben wurden sechs millionen
menschen warten auf behandlungen und da
ist natürlich jedes krankenhaus peters
momentan mit einem kurve patienten
belegt ist eine neue sorge wie geht es
einem statement von merlin der meinte
die uefa ist sollte eine neue
infektionsfälle ausbrechen mindestens
mit schuldig das geht auch in die
richtung der frage die ich
aufgeschrieben hat 60.000 menschen im
wembley-stadion und gestern hunderte
haben versucht sei illegal reinzukommen
also das gar nicht nach anderthalb meter
abstand
15cm stand dies ist schon auswirkungen
der der spiele in den beinen kann man
ablesen oder ist es der spielfluss dann
weiß ich bin also aus rom liegen uns
noch keine daten vor aber wie du schon
sagst konnte man das er gestern ganz gut
beobachten
wenn da ein super scanner dabei war dann
war das sicherlich schlecht die leute
die sich da rein gedrängelt haben haben
natürlich nicht nur darauf verzichte
tickets zu machen sondern bestimmt auch
vorher den obligatorischen kogge test
hochzuladen und waren vermutlich nicht
getestet das erhöht das risiko natürlich
nochmal schottland allerdings habt nach
dem schottischen spielen eine
untersuchung gestartet und geht davon
aus dass insgesamt 5000 infektionen auf
diese fußballspiele zurückzuführen waren
das war allerdings nur solange überhaupt
im rennen war ist also schon eine weile
her und daran kann man ablesen
diese stadien waren deutlich spärlicher
besetzt und lieber zu diesem zeitpunkt
auch deutlich spärlicher besetzt als das
gestern und bei den beiden halbfinales
der fall war also ich denke schon dass
man davon ausgehen muss dass einige
infektion sich bei den letzten spielen
noch ereignet haben soll ich hier eine
frage von sascha oder die fragten
kommentatoren noch zeigen mit der
verfügbarkeit von impfstoff für alle
müssen die einschränkungen deutlich
zurückgenommen werden aus gesellschafts
schutz wird der selbstbestimmte schutz
wir sind noch in einer übergangszeit
dazu passt jetzt genau die problematik
die wir haben mit dem astra zeneca
wirkstoff oder abstimmungen
dagegen stellt eine ganze nicht so
wirksam sein soll
ist das tatsächlich auch eine diskussion
die in großbritannien geführt wird dass
man sagt okay wir haben zwar nirgends
stock und wir haben für den dienst aber
eigentlich nicht mit dem
wirkungsvollsten müssen wochen vorne
anfangen also insgesamt ist die skepsis
gegenüber über astra zeneca hier
wirklich sehr gering ausgeprägt deutlich
geringer als in deutschland die leute
lassen sich alle mit astrazeneca impfen
wenn das angeboten wird und die
nachfrage nach impfstoff ist hier
unvermindert groß arsenal stadion war in
den letzten tagen zu sehen dass drei
viertel eine eine schlange drei viertel
ums stadion ging weil es dort nämlich
impfungen ohne termin gab und die leute
reißen sich förmlich darum jetzt
besonders vor den sommerferien gab es
sogar richtigen ärger bei ärzten die
bedroht wurden weil die leute ihre
zweite info früher haben wollten damit
sie ohne restriktionen ins ausland
fahren können also impfmüdigkeit ist ja
nicht zu verspüren und astrazeneca wird
auch weiterhin angenommen
tatsächlich ist es so dass im herbst ein
dritter eine dritte impfung in der
diskussion ist eben einfach um die
e-mobilität zu stärken und noch einmal
aufzufrischen und womöglich auch um
gewisse schwachstellen die die
bisherigen impfstoffe im zusammenhang
mit neuen varianten aufweisen
auszugleichen diana vielen dank und dann
kannst du dich jetzt wieder aus der
bewegung heraus bewegen
es würde uns gerade gefragt ob man
diesen hübschen zdf stimmen bekommen
kann nein kann man nicht aber ich kann
mir schon anderen zeigen dass
kontrolleure blog guckt man ja sonst im
zdf shop habe ich auch gerufen
einmal auf meinem bildschirm den kriegt
ihr nicht aber ihr könnt diesen kaufen
den mainzelmännchen taschen schirme fast
genau so schön so jetzt haben wir auch
noch die werbung abgearbeitet und können
zu tobias hans com ministerpräsident des
saarlandes der sich heute dazu geäußert
hat was er denkt was das richtige die
die richtigen maßnahmen der richtige
umgang mit der derzeitigen situation ist
und wir hören mal rein was er da gesagt
hat
wir müssen unsere maßnahmen immer dann
an dem orientieren was tatsächlich das
infektionsgeschehen hergibt wir haben
derzeit sehr niedrige zahlen in
deutschland
deswegen ist es geboten auch freiheiten
wiederherzustellen die stehenden
menschen zu und so wird es sicherlich
auch weiterhin lockerungen geben müssen
denn die zahlen niedrig bleibende
infektion
das kann man jetzt nicht sozusagen alles
absagen nur weil eine gefahr droht wir
sollten durchaus mutig und noch
optimistisch jetzt in diesem sommer und
herbst gehen wir haben einen guten
fortschritt mittlerweile wir müssen
ihnen aber weiter ausbauen und es muss
ein signal an die menschen auch gesendet
werden wenn ihr euch impfen lassen wenn
der im fortschritt voran geht dann
werden wir eine weitgehende
normalisierung auch bekommen das ist ein
ganz wichtiges signal wenn wir jetzt
hingehen und wieder alles zu sperren da
werden die menschen auch nicht bereit
sind sich impfen zu lassen
also mutig und optimistisch ist tobias
hans ministerpräsident des saarlandes
und wir schalten in genau das bundesland
zur universität des landes quasi zum
professor thorsten er professor für
klinische pharmazie und mitautor
programmierer des simulators einen
schönen guten abend ein wunderschönes
land teilen sie denn diesen optimismus
und diesen mut ihres ministerpräsidenten
wenn sie auf ihre profi simulation mit
der delta variante gucken ja ich glaube
wir müssen ein bisschen differenziert
drauf schauen also zum einen haben wir
gerade wirklich sehr niedrige fallzahlen
und inzidenz das ist zum einen richtig
und die bevölkerung dürstet natürlich
nach lockerung nach einer gewissen
normalität das ist erstmal richtig und
das ist letztendlich auch wichtig dass
wir da eine gewisse ja eine gewisse
menge an freiheiten wieder zurückgeben
wir müssen aber genau schauen welche
dieser freiheiten wirklich gut sind und
welche wir wirklich zurückgeben sollten
und welche maßnahmen ja auch
zurücknehmen wenn wir jetzt schauen wie
sich eigentlich die fallzahlen
entwickeln dann sehen wir eigentlich in
deutschland jetzt ein ähnliches bild wie
wird es in großbritannien eigentlich
auch ab dem mai gesehen haben das heißt
die fallzahlen stagnieren jetzt hier in
deutschland bzw steigen leicht wieder
und das maß wie die fallzahlen ja auch
in deutschland steigen ist eigentlich
ungefähr mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit wie es auch in
frankreich bzw
in england steigt oder gestiegen ist
also wir sind ja jetzt noch lange nicht
durch und ist der impfschutz schritt
reicht eben nicht aus das sehen wir an
israel das sind wir eben auch an
großbritannien das sehen wir aber auch
in deutschland wo wir 24 geimpft haben
aber immer noch es nicht ist jeder
zweite erstmal noch nicht vollständig
geimpft und von daher bin ich noch nicht
ganz so optimistisch wie das herr hans
ist sind denn die situation in
großbritannien und in frankreich und
dann auch in deutschland miteinander
überhaupt vergleichbar da muss man
mittlerweile feststellen dass sich das
da ganz anders verhält und deswegen auch
jeweils ein anderer weg in ordnung und
möglich ist
ja also ich glaube eigentlich nicht dass
diese situation wirklich so komplett
unterschiedlicher sie kommen nur zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten
großbritannien ist so eine art vorreiter
zum einen was die impfungen angeht zum
einen aber auch als die delta variante
angeht und auch was lockerungen und
anstieg von fallzahlen wieder angeht
also hier hatten wir sehr hohe
fallzahlen über den winter dann sehr
harte maßnahmen dann kamen die delta
variante die impfung und dann
stiegen die zahlen jetzt endlich wieder
an das gleiche sehen wir jetzt eben
zeitversetzt ungefähr vier bis sechs
wochen später halt auch eigentlich im
rest von europa bzw vor allem bei uns
gerade in deutschland und in frankreich
die drei länder haben letztendlich alle
auf einem unterschiedlichen niveau auch
angehalten abzusenken und das macht noch
einen großen unterschied weil dieses
wachstum und vor allem das was man dann
sieht sieht sehr viel dramatischer aus
wenn sie wie in england zum beispiel
wenn der incidents von 20 fällen pro
sieben tage pro 100000 einwohner wieder
anfangen zu wachsen als in deutschland
jetzt vielleicht bei sieben fällen also
vergleichbar ist das schon wir haben
vielleicht ein bisschen eine bessere
ausgangssituation und möglicherweise
auch den besseren impfstoff hierfür die
delta variante wie würden sie denn jetzt
die unterschiedlichen ansätze die sind
jedoch sehr unterschiedlich von
präsident marco und präsident boris
johnson
wie würden sie die bewährten also würden
sie einen der beiden wege auch für
deutschland empfehlen oder bevorzugen
oder würden sie sagen wir brauchen noch
mal ganz dritten ganz anderen ja also
ich bin prinzipiell erst mal ganz froh
gerade nicht in england zu leben und zu
wohnen das muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
finde das vorgehen dort und sehr
gefährlich also diese diese geplante
durch solche in der bevölkerung finde
ich ja fast fahrlässig wir sehen auch
dort dass die fallzahlen in den
krankenhäusern wieder stark ansteigen
auch wenn wir dort eine durchimpfung
haben sehen wir jetzt gerade das bild
und der ton das ist dann manchmal das
problem mit diesen internetverbindungen
die hängen sich im digital deutschland
auch mal auf ich guck mal ob wir bauen
die verbindung auf würde ich sagen zu
herrn professor lehr
ich schau mal in die kommt erst wieder
davon jetzt ist jetzt dass hier bei mir
der computer spinnt er ist auch noch gut
heute ist der wurm drin aber herr
professor ist wieder da das ist doch
auch gut
sie hat mich auch wieder ja prima genau
ich weiß nicht genau wo ich aufgehört
habe die situation in england das
spiegelt sich letztendlich die
steigenden fallzahlen reflektieren sich
dort auch schon wieder in den
krankenhauseinweisungen also dort haben
in den letzten vier wochen ungefähr auch
schon eine vervierfachung der täglichen
krankenhausaufnahmen wieder gesehen dort
gehen momentan wieder täglich 400 fälle
ins krankenhaus während das vor ungefähr
vier wochen noch 100 fälle waren also
eine deutliche verschärfung der
situation und das ist natürlich
nachgelegt und jetzt um auf die frage
zurückzukommen was ist der richtige weg
ich denke der wichtige weg ist erstmal
dass wir uns alle impfen lassen und dass
wir uns deshalb bewusst sind dass die
impfung halt wirklich ein ganz wichtiger
faktor ist und dass wir vor allem mit
dieser delta variante eine sehr hohe
durchimpfungsrate brauchen also
idealerweise müsste bei 85 bis 90
prozent der geimpften rauskommen die
sich impfen lassen dürfen und das ist
und das wurde auch schon in den medien
diskutiert vielleicht eine utopische und
nicht zu erreichende zahl
das heißt also hier könnten wir das
problem schon haben dass wir diese
herdenimmunität durch die reine eben
nicht erreichen und das ist es dann halt
eben dazu kommt das was herr drosten
auch schon sagte dass wer sich nicht
impfen lässt letztendlich sich
infizieren wird wir haben von daher
finde ich diese genau da ist die
situation in frankreich sicherlich die
bessere und natürlich auch den ansporn
zur impfung den finde ich erstmal ganz
wichtig und ich hoffe dass wir in
deutschland hier mit der impfung jetzt
auch nicht noch weiter nachlassen
und ja noch weiter dranbleiben es gab
aber auch professor kollege quasi gesagt
hat so hätten die militärs ist sowieso
nicht zu erreichen ist das eine illusion
wir müssen damit leben dass hier quasi
dieses virus immer wieder andere
variationen um die ohren gehauen
bekommen in den nächsten jahren das ist
nicht auch eine möglichkeit
ja sicher als ich glaube an irgendeiner
stelle wenn wir uns vielleicht damit
anfreunden müssen dass wir damit leben
wie auch mit der influenza aber wir
wissen und wir sehen auch dass diese
varianten die uns hier jetzt um die
ohren segeln auch immer stärker werden
immer schwerwiegender werden und wir
wissen noch nicht ob die ende zu ende
der fahnenstange erreicht ist also hier
ist noch potenzial luft nach oben aber
auch luft nach unten was die entwicklung
des virus angeht das problem das wir
natürlich haben beide instanzen wie sie
jetzt zum beispiel auch in england zu
sehen sind es dass bei diesen hohen
virus lasten natürlich auch viele neue
mutationen auftreten können also dass da
eine zweite platte britische variante
auftritt das ist sicherlich möglich und
das kann natürlich woanders auch
passieren deswegen sollten eigentlich
aus meiner sicht diese fallzahlen nicht
so stark ansteigen und wir sollten
schauen dass wir das besser in den griff
bekommen und vor allem auch in
deutschland und auch in anderen orten
wie die kontakt nachverfolgung bei
instanzen von 400 oder 800 war
sicherlich sehr schwierig sein und dann
gerät natürlich so eine pandemie oder
auch letztendlich die situation bei uns
kann leicht außer kontrolle geraten
deswegen bin ich da jetzt nicht für frei
für freie bürger und incident since
unendliche zu schießen das wird sich am
ende des tages rächen
aber ist es nicht so dass die delta
variante zwar ansteckender ist aber
nicht unbedingt tödlicher also nicht
unbedingt zum schwereren verlauf führt
und wenn jetzt gerade die älteren die
variablen gruppen geimpft sind dass man
dann sagen muss okay dann haben wir halt
viele menschen die ein zwei drei vier
wochen danieder liegen und auch
vielleicht ins krankenhaus müssen aber
wir haben nicht mehr eine situation wie
vor einem jahr will man wirklich damit
rechnen musste jeden tag 2 34 500 600
tote zu haben ja ich gehe schon davon
aus dass also die mortalität deutlich
sinken wird jetzt durch die impfungen
und auch durch die verschiebung der
altersstruktur sie wir sehen jetzt
einfach viel mehr jüngere patientinnen
und patienten die infiziert sind im
vergleich zum winter und auch im
krankenhaus werden die die belegung
durch deutlich jüngere patientinnen und
patienten geregelt
aber nichtsdestotrotz haben wir das
gerade auch schon gehört es gibt
natürlich auch durchbrüche bei den
impfungen das heißt also auch bereits
geimpfte können auch verläuft die
teilweise ein bisschen schwerer sind sie
können auch leute wieder infizieren und
wir ich werde mir nicht so sicher ob es
wirklich nicht auch zu einer vermehrten
aus vitalisierung kommt wir wissen dass
letztendlich von der alpha varianten der
britische das tor zu treffen hätten
krankenhaus und intensiv anweisung kam
haben und ich gehe eigentlich davon aus
dass das diese delta variante auch
zeigen wird wie stark die ist das bleibt
noch ein bisschen abzuwarten
ich möchte jetzt hier auch keinerlei
schwarz malerei oder horrorszenarien
betreiben aber hier ist schon auch noch
eine chance dass uns hier auch dann im
herbst wenn die situation sich
möglicherweise durch das abnehmen der
saisonalität auch noch verschärft hier
auch trotzdem noch eine stärkere welle
auch wieder am gilt beim
gesundheitswesen hingegen schlagen wird
jetzt seid ihr benny da eine frage der
meinte haben sie doch schon angesprochen
der bayern der wirkstoff von paion tag
ist gegen die delta variante wird
wirksam
ich glaube der von moderner auch also
die mnh wirkstoffe scheinen da besser zu
helfen
und er sagt oder fragt hat deutschland
eine bessere chance durch die nächste
welle zu kommen weil sie mehr mit
biontech impft einerseits weil bei
montech wirksamer gegen data ist und man
leichter außerdem den wirkstoff
modifizieren kann also haben wir da auch
dann nicht auch einen vorteil und können
sagen okay also klar ist alles nicht
super aber wir müssen hier keine panik
verbreiten
ja also panik verbreiten
wieso erst mal nicht ich glaube wir
müssen einfach ein bisschen was haben
und aufmerksam sein für das was kommt
und vor allem bereit sein auch uns
wieder zu adaptieren
ich denke schon dass wir mit dem biotech
und dem moderner wirkstoff hier ganz gut
aufgestellt sind sind gerade gesagt den
kann man auch gut adaptieren aber wir
müssen natürlich bedenken dass diese
adaption auch erst mal durchgeführt
werden müssen sie müssen auch klinisch
geprüft wenn also all das muss natürlich
auch getan werden das wurde im letzten
jahr mit einer rekordgeschwindigkeit
durchgeführt und wir müssen mal schauen
wie schnell das hier geht und ob wir mit
der modifikation auch den varianten dann
wirklich hinterher kommen wir sind
sicherlich auf einem sehr glücklichen
weg das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
stellen sie sich mal vor wir hätten
keine impfstoff es gibt genug werden und
bakterien gegen die sie keine impfungen
wir haben und da sind wir in der
glücklichen situation unsere unsere
zukunftsperspektive würde ganz anders
aussehen wenn dieser impfstoff nicht
funktionieren würde von daher bin ich da
erst mal grund optimistisch dass wir das
auch mit modifikationen wieder in den
griff kriegen aber es ist ein gewisses
katz und maus spiel und natürlich auch
ein rennen gegen die uhr
also ich habe jetzt hier so ein
lieblings user gerade am start der die
anderen im chat dazu auffordert diesen
kanal runter zu voten ist ein netter
versuch aber ist auch ein bisschen
armselig also das ist doch einfach sein
du kannst auch irgendwo anders
beschäftigen denn wenn du nichts mit
seinem leben anzufangen weiß
wenn wir jetzt sehen dass großbritannien
fußball-em da war einiges los leute sind
gereist die grenzen sind offen weiterhin
kann sich das auswirken auf uns dann
auch westeuropa großbritannien ist eine
insel das heißt da kommt nicht so viel
rüber das ist der natürliche vorteil
aber trotzdem gibt es dann ein höheres
risiko
ja wir haben sicherlich jetzt im laufe
der partie mehren wir schon gesehen dass
er letztendlich nichts dicht und nicht
sicher ist und es einen übertrag immer
geben kann
ich glaube aber schon eigentlich auch
das jetzt momentan aus großbritannien
nicht so viel wieder zurück kompressen
hochrisiko gebietes dort gewissen
sicherheitsmaßnahmen gelten was noch
reiserückkehrer angeht und die menge der
dort hingereist natürlich auch endlich
ist das ist sicherlich etwas anderes als
wenn wir jetzt vielleicht den
europaweiten sommerurlaub anschauen
deswegen glaube ich dann wird es
vielleicht ein gewissen übertrag geben
aber ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt bei
uns die pandemie
explosionsartig nach oben treibt ich
glaube aber schon dass und das hat die
korrespondentin aus london schon gesagt
dass wir hier sicherlich in den relativ
starken anstieg auch in england noch
sehen werden durch die ereignisse der
halbfinal- und finalspiele werden sie ja
doch im jenseits sämtliche
abstandsregeln durchgeführt wurden ich
habe ja noch ein paar kommentare sind
ganz interessant also der eine von
raimund böhringer auf facebook der
meinte ich verstehe englands weg nicht
bei einer quote von knapp über 50
prozent kann man doch nicht mit der
ungehinderten durchseuchung beginnen
also das ist auf jeden fall auf ihre
argumentationslinie simons perm hat aber
ganz sachlich mal betrachtet man kann
den leuten nicht noch mal alles
verbieten und vorschreiben das wird
keiner mehr mitmachen und das weißt
beziehungsweise wissen die politiker
auch ganz genau da ist boris johnson
auch jemand der genau da versucht immer
den die stimmung im volk zu treffen die
scheint ja in großbritannien gespalten
zu sein haben sie nicht das gefühl dass
man die menschen es noch mal überzeugen
kann irgendwie sich die nächsten monate
zusammen zu reißen oder sie schneller
impfen zu lassen
oder muss man jetzt einfach sagen okay
das scheint er die linie zu sein von
boris johnson ist selbst verantwortlich
ihr seid erwachsenen dann macht halt ja
wie sie schon sagen das ist letztendlich
es ist eine demokratie in der wir leben
und es ist sehr schwierig hier auch
wirklich die bürgerinnen und bürger
wirklich zu bewegen und in england
scheint es gerade sehr schwer zu sein
aber das gleiche problem sie wieder in
deutschland auch wenn sicherlich ist die
situation in england jetzt anders und es
wird dann sicherlich auch die eine
hälfte geben die sich entsprechend
schützt so wie wir das halt auch kennen
und das wird die andere geben die dann
sehr proaktiv weil das risiko sucht ich
glaube wir müssen und das was wir vorhin
schon gesagt wir müssen langfristig
vielleicht eine strategie entwickeln wie
wir mit diesem virus wirklich gut leben
können
aber wichtig ist halt trotz allem noch
die durchimpfung einfach zu steigern das
ist ein sehr einfacher weg raus aber der
lässt die bereitschaft in england nach
unterlässt bei uns in deutschland die
bereitschaft auch schon sehr stark nach
und das ist natürlich dann immer auch
ein problem dass sie jetzt in
deutschland bei diesen niedrigen in
sequenzen die freiheiten dann
entsprechend zurückgeben das heißt dann
gibt mit der anreiz einfach entsprechend
gesenkt und das ist natürlich eine
problematik dann auch die impfung weiter
voranzutreiben und da kann ich man
braucht kann man nur hoffen dass die
guten argumentation helfen
ich bin ja auch bei herrn kühne ich
glaube nicht dass wir diese im boden die
wenig brauchen hier erreichen werden
und von daher wird es sicherlich ein ja
ein weiteres bestehen dieses corona
virus parallel zu anderen infektion
ihren wahrscheinlich geben begleiten
jetzt gerade so wissen in so eine
demokratie theoretische diskussion hat
da sind sie nicht der fachmann für sie
habe aber trotzdem noch eine eine
wortmeldung einfach die ich jetzt noch
mal hier rein werfen möchte damit die
auch abgebildet ist von expressen der
meinte ich verschiedene diskussion nicht
selbst wenn die zahlen steigen ist es
eine komplett andere situation wie vor
einem jahr viele sind geimpft des herbst
werden es noch mehr sein aufmachen alles
sofort denn es gibt überhaupt keine
rechtliche grundlage auch vermutungen
was sein könnte
weiter alles zuzulassen aber ich habe
eine frage die habe ich gerade gesehen
vielleicht die könnten sie beantworten
da geht es nämlich tatsächlich um so
eine frage von daniel jeder meint
großbritannien und frankreich testen
mehr als alle anderen in europa ich
hätte gerne genaue zahlen zu den
falsch-positiven und positiv geimpften
bevor panik gemacht wird also panik
haben sie gerade schon gesagt wollen sie
nicht verbreiten aber die frage ist kann
man überhaupt das so genau sagen wie
viele von den tests falsch positiv sind
um sich dann wirklich ein komplett
exaktes bild von der lage zu machen
na gut ich meine das problem dass etwas
komplett exakten willis ist natürlich
immer wirklich schwierig also auch wie
sie sagen mit denen mit den tests die
sind natürlich teilweise sehr
unterschiedlich es gibt jetzt in
deutschland auch die diskussion weil
natürlich die schnelltests welchen
effekt haben die da zeigen ja gewisse
erhebungen auch dass von diesem
schnelltest von den positiven
schnelltest zum beispiel auch nur zehn
prozent in etwa und eher weniger als
zehn prozent zu einem positiven pcr-test
geführt haben also diese test situation
ist sicherlich kompliziert und noch ein
bisschen undurchsichtig geworden durch
diese schnelltests in der letzten zeit
ich glaube es ist ganz schwierig die
einzelnen länder wirklich komplett auch
miteinander zu vergleichen weil es da
unterschiedliche test konzepte gibt die
freiwillig getestet wird
aber ich glaube trotzdem auch dass wir
jetzt eben eigentlich einer glücklichen
situation sind wie diesen impfstoff
haben und wo wir auch eigentlich die
möglichkeit haben noch den einzelnen zu
schützen und zu dem kommentar davor
möchte ich vielleicht nur sagen
natürlich können wir das aufmachen und
begehrteste er ist in der glücklichen
situation wenn nicht geimpft ist der
setzt sich halten
selbst dem risiko aus das müssen wir
wissen aber das problem dass ich halt
immer hier sehe ist eigen bestimmtheit
und eigenes risiko ist das eine aber ich
habe natürlich damit auch immer noch die
möglichkeit jemand anderes zu infizieren
der sich vielleicht eben nicht impfen
lassen kann also sprich kinder und
jugendliche und ich glaube da geht es
natürlich auch noch darum die
bevölkerungsteile zu schützen die sich
eben noch nicht impfen lassen dürfen
oder können und ja das weiß ich aus
sagte wir müssen einfach schauen dass
wir die inzidenz nicht zu weit nach oben
treiben weil sonst können auch wieder
neue mutanten entstehen und dann kann es
sein dass unsere wirkstoffe oder
impfstoffe eben nicht mehr wirken und
das ist halt eine situation eben auch
nicht haben wollen weil ich gerade
gefragt wurde chat die es bei uns
aussieht im zdf mit impfungen wir haben
hier von unseren betriebsarzt einer
eigenen station meine zweite impfung das
übermorgen von daher ja wir lassen uns
impfen
fernanda hat eine ganz spannende frage
hergestellt welches verhältnis von
geimpften zu ungeimpften bietet dem
virus das beste umfeld zur bildung von
escape varianten müssen wir kurz
erklären als gelb varianten sind quasi
die mutationen die dann dazu dafür
sorgen dass der wirkstoff der impfstoff
nicht mehr wirkt und quasi das virus
flüchten kann in doch noch in den
nächsten wird macht großbritannien da
einen fehler also gibt es da schon
erkenntnisse welches verhältnis da gut
ist damit eben keiner es gibt varianten
entstehen ja also ich denke ich kann ja
jetzt keine genauen zahlen sagen aber es
ist sicherlich gerade eine situation in
der wir uns befinden wo ungefähr die
hälfte geimpft also vollständig gegen
die andere hälfte nicht vollständig
geimpft ist
die definitiven selektionsdruck bietet
weil natürlich dann auch eine hohe zahl
von erkrankten nicht geimpften auch auf
geimpfte treffen und dort sich natürlich
eine gute möglichkeit der verbreitung
von ja escape varianten ein fach
anbietet also ich glaube nicht dass es
auch wirklich eine komplette zahl gibt
aber so ein äquivalenzverhältnis wie wir
sie jetzt momentan haben sich schon für
eigentlich eine ganz gute brutstätte
auch für issey varianten
das hat mir natürlich vorher als wir
wenig impfung hat nicht da haben sich
letztendlich war das survival of the
fittest und diese es kay varianten sind
auch nicht immer unbedingt die die sich
am schnellsten am meisten reproduzieren
sondern die hat ihre nische suchen und
die nische ist in dem fall natürlich
dann der geimpfte der geimpfte wird und
da sehe ich schon auch eine gewisse
chance dass ich da was
ja was breit macht und was entwickelt
und auch entsprechend ja fortpflanzt
wenn man das so sagen kann ich schauen
wir mal ob es eine frage gibt an sie die
wir irgendwie beantworten können es gibt
natürlich ein paar kommentare hier wie
immer die sich gegen alles sperren also
die komplette dogmatisch sind und sagen
so alles auf machen freiheit ist
wichtiger als alles andere das haben
wahrscheinlich einige menschen die eine
ähnliche einstellung hatten irgendwann
bereut als hier auf der intensivstation
gelegen haben
hier gibt es noch einen kommentar von
roma aus brasilien wird von delta
zunehmend dominiert sogar mal aus
brasilien ist die nächste variante ist
gibt es da auch schon irgendwie
anzeichen dass die überschwappen könnte
also werden wir quasi jetzt nur noch von
von einem buchstaben zum nächsten hüpfen
ja also die gute frage wird sein wie wir
sind wir beim omega angekommen und was
kommt danach aber erstmal natürlich gama
ist sicherlich eine variante die auch in
deutschland schon vorhanden ist sie hat
sich jetzt erstmal nicht ausgebreitet
ich gehe davon aus dass delta sich jetzt
erst mal komplett ausbreitet dann wird
die frage sein
es kann letztendlich wirklich
infektiöser da bin ich mir noch nicht
ganz sicher die daten zeigen dass noch
nicht wirklich wir hatten da auch
sicherlich immer viele vermutungen als
die südafrikanische varianten geht also
das kann gut sein dass man sich
entsprechend ausbreitet das kann aber
auch sein dass wir vielleicht eine
zweite britische variante oder was auch
immer vielleicht als nächstes hier
begrüßen also wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen dass die alpha variante zu uns
gekommen ist das war jetzt im januar wir
haben sie mehr oder weniger schon wieder
komplett vergessen der älter ist jetzt
komplett dominant und die möglichkeit
dass da die nächste variante kommt ist
gegeben viele von denen sind auch schon
in kleinen prozentzahlen vorhanden oft
natürlich erst mal einen kleinen
clustern und ausbrüchen die noch
kontrolliert werden aber wenn du das
infektionsgeschehen wieder zunimmt dann
kann es hier natürlich auch wieder zu
einer ausbreitung von einer weiteren
variante kommen die entsprechenden
dominanter ist moment sehe ich sie nicht
aber auch da müssen einfach die
varianten weiter anschauen und auch
weiter sequenzieren das wird ganz
wichtig sein damit war das lernen
verstehen um rechtzeitig reagieren
können so jetzt gerade die ersten
eilmeldungen aus der rede von präsident
ma con frankreichs präsident mal kommt
der jetzt gerade während wir hier
streamen
seine rede zur lage der nation an die
nation richtet und da kann
wer schon mal mit teilen also er sagt
wenn wir jetzt nicht handeln dann werden
sich die fall werden die preise weiter
steigen und auch die zahl der
hospitalisierungen also der menschen in
den krankenhäusern und er sagt kobi 19
impfungen werden für alle die im
gesundheitsbereich arbeiten in
frankreich verpflichtend das sind so
also quasi die ersten informationen aus
der ansprache von präsident marc der
geht er jetzt mit etwas härteren
bandagen wohl vor also die
entgegensetzte weg so präsident boris
johnson im vereinigten königreich haben
wir ja auch schon drüber gesprochen
john fahrkarten eine frage hier sind
club öffnungen jetzt eigentlich nicht zu
früh erfolgt man hört ja auch davon dass
zum beispiel vor klubs nicht richtig
getestet wird oder die zertifikate
herumgeschickt werden also dass es dazu
fälschungen kommt was übrigens experten
schon ganz am anfang haben kommen sehen
wenn es mal soweit kommt dass man
nachweisen kann werden menschen
versuchen das zu fälschen also club
öffnungen zu früh ich ahne ihrer antwort
professor dr
ja ich hab da natürlich ein ambivalentes
verhältnis weil wir auch ein projekt in
stuttgart haben wo wir uns um öffnung
von der kulturszene ein bisschen mehr
mühe
ich glaube wir müssen die kontrolliert
öffnen ich glaube diese öffnung wie sie
jetzt natürlich gefordert und vielfach
auch durchgeführt wird die funktioniert
halt eben nicht und das zeigen halt die
beispiele da haben wir auch ein beispiel
aus holland
was enschede wo sich bei einem club
besuch von 600 personen mindestens schon
mal knapp 200 angesteckt haben das haben
wir an anderen stellen auch das passiert
natürlich schnell also die aerosole
haben da natürlich eine gute
verbreitungsmöglichkeiten und wie sie
schon sagen erfolgt auch die eine oder
andere jahr fälschung nachahmung von
test zertifikaten und das ist natürlich
dann eine gewisse selbstgefährdung die
die besucherinnen und besucher darauf
eingehen aber das halte ich halt auch
für riskant und gefährlich also ich
glaube da müssen wir diese systeme oder
diese öffnung einfach auch mit system
vornehmen und das ist natürlich da das
spiegelt sich einfach der der
widerspruch wieder das sehe ich eben
auch an dem gespräch mit den betreibern
die natürlich sehr lange wirklich
gelitten haben das muss ich sagen das
sind ja die die als erstes zu gemacht
haben und als letztes überhaupt wieder
aufmachen können dann wahrscheinlich als
erstes wieder zu machen müssen oder wie
auch immer das da weiter geht also das
heißt wir haben
wirklich ein sehr hohes leib getragen
und sind natürlich auch sehr daran
interessiert wieder eine normalität zu
bekommen aber ich glaube die innenraum
diskotheken sind sicherlich ein
schwieriger ort wo wir wirklich genau
aufpassen müssen dass wir uns da auch
nicht ja ein zweites spiel noch einmal
einhalten oder mehrere gestützt jetzt
habe ich eine spannende frage von 1994
was ist denn die planen wenn die impfung
bei variante xy sie haben ja gesagt
irgendwann kommt man am ende des
alphabets an des griechischen dann muss
man von vorne anfangen oder
durchnummerieren nichts mehr nützt also
kann man in so eine situation kommen
oder ist es dann so dass wir irgendwann
so ein bisschen zumindest irgendwie
gegen diesen diesen virustyp resistent
sind und dann nur noch säuglinge und
kinder betroffen sind diese eine leichte
form davon dann kriegen und der rest hat
sich daran mehr oder weniger gewöhnt und
hat dann quasi eine erkältung und liegt
zwei tage flach und geht dann wieder
arbeiten
ja da sind sich die experten wirklich
noch nicht so richtig einig in welche
richtung das gehen kann also es kann
natürlich so zur klassischen abflachung
der symptome kommen das ist eine
möglichkeit aber es kann natürlich auch
noch zu einer verschlimmerung kommen das
virus hat halt wirklich im vergleich zu
vielen anderen viren diese ganz schöne
eigenschaft das ist halt ja auch eine
infektiosität schon hat bevor wirklich
symptome eigentlich manifestiert sind
das heißt also dann wenn wir einfach
ganz gesund und normal erscheinen können
wie jemand anders schon infizieren und
das ist sehr clever von dem virus
ausgedacht also das ist ein sehr gutes
feature zur verbreitung wie das
weitergeht das müssen wir letztendlich
schauen es kann sicherlich sein
irgendwann wird es halt dazu kommen dass
jeder infiziert war und dass wir uns
halt vielleicht regelmäßig damit
infizieren wie wir uns auch mit zb
herpes simplex virus haben ja auch mehr
oder weniger nur durch und kontrollieren
ist und manchmal wird das halt
entsprechend ausbrechen ich glaube schon
dass das und ich hoffe schon dass die
biologie sich hier in den weg bahnen
wird
wichtig wird sein dass das was jetzt
auch von der bundesregierung gefördert
wird vermehrt auch programme gibt die
nicht nur auf die impfung abzielen
sondern auch wirklich auf die behandlung
das ist erstmal ganz wichtig dass ich
auch wirklich für die kliniken für den
einzelnen behandlungen haben weil wir
dürfen eine sache nicht vergessen und
das ist natürlich epidemiologisch sich
die situation vielleicht gerade gut aus
aber für diejenigen der halt eben krank
ist und gerade auf der intensivstation
liegt oder möglicherweise auch beatmet
werden muss oder auch anna an so einer
ecke hängt er für den sich die situation
alles andere als rosig aus und da nützt
es nichts wenn die fallzahlen niedrig
hier sich selbst aber
schwer krank bin also das muss nicht
jeder einzelne auch immer wieder bewusst
machen
das ist eine schwerwiegende erkrankung
die deutlich gefährlicher ist als
influenza also die krippe und hier
brauchen wir eben auch medikamente und
das wird möglicherweise dann ein weg
sein wie wir da rauskommen aber das wird
uns die zukunft lernen und auch ein
bisschen wie die bevölkerung damit
umgeht glaube das ist die erste panne
dieser art für die meisten von uns oder
eigentlich für alle von uns und ja ich
glaube das trifft natürlich jetzt noch
auf das war ja und ich habe da eine
gewisse hoffnung dass ich nach den
wahlen vielleicht auch eine gewisse
normalität und auch wieder eine
weitsicht einstellt die momentan
vielleicht noch zu vermissen lässt hast
du ja vielen dank dass sie heute wieder
für uns zeit hatten uns alles
beantwortet haben
ich sollte mal bis zum nächsten mal dann
nicht dagegen eine thema wird uns noch
weiter begleiten
ich habe noch ein paar anmeldungen hier
aus frankreich ich muss mal kurz
übersetzten weil dir kommt es gerade
noch auf englisch an also von
französisch auf englisch übersetzt und
ich muss jetzt noch mal zurück
übersetzen
also präsident kündigt an dass es für
events mit über 50 leuten ab dem 21
juli das ist bald in zwei wochen nötig
sein wird dass man einen gesundheitspass
vorliegt also quasi einen nachweis über
seinen gesundheitszustand und den wird
man auch brauchen um in bars restaurants
flugzeugen und eben züge zu kommen ab
anfang august das meldet gerade reuters
aus der rede des französischen
präsidenten und die impfkampagne für
high und mittels kurs to dance also für
etwas ältere schüler und studenten wird
starten wenn die wieder ende des sommers
in die schulen gehen soweit also
aktuelle meldungen aus frankreich wie es
dort weitergeht für heute sage ich
vielen dank fürs zuschauen fürs
mitmachen und noch ein kommentar die
nicht vorlesen möchte den ich gerade
gefunden habe von gutem anwandte city
endlich wach ich sage heute nicht mehr
denn der tag war lang aber bis zum
nächsten winter wieder völlig was für
euch da bis dahin sah ich mach's gut
grundschutz
[Musik]